today are we going to be going over many
different type of end games so basically
we're going to be focusing lots of
different Indian positions and the first
position I have is the following endgame
is white to play and the goal in this
position is to win upon to win this d5
pawn okay that's what you're trying to
do so the goal will be to find a way to
win this d5 pawn here so let's think
about it for a minute or two and
calculate some possibilities here that
you can try to do here
first of all when the pond is by itself
in the middle of the board what do we
call the spawn isolated pawn so remember
the pawn by itself it's an isolated pawn
now what can we do in this endgame
that's white
in order to win the pond you have to
first attack it so that's the first idea
right so but the problem is seen up
there is a danger of him advancing the
spawn and exchanging it simply so that's
why you have to make sure you play the
right move here raise your hand if you
have any idea here that what can you do
to win this pawn in the middle of the
board yes very good idea you go Knight
e3 and now you want to win the pawn so
you have two pieces attacking but looks
like it's a problem he just pushes it
and he's going to simply try to exchange
this week pawn if you have a weak point
in the middle of the board you always
want to exchange the pawn push up
well we could we could play this move
but I don't know if it's really going to
do that much for us we could do that we
could we go back with relating push and
now we go back we had talked again now
we have three pieces attacking on it
looks like no choice he has to push it
again
don't rush here think don't rush
remember if you see a good move look for
a better one 91 is very natural but
maybe you have something even better
nine to d4 that's the very nice idea
that I wanted to you to see night goes
on d4 blocking the rook looks like you
can just take it right so he doesn't
take it we just simply take the pawn
we're going to win this game so he takes
it what did you capture the bishop no
the pawn and now we haven't pinned C by
a neat maneuver with a knight you're
going to be able to win this pawn and
here you can slowly convert into a win
with extra pawn if you had a kimochi one
could you do the same thing why exactly
the King was on g1 he would have gone
Bishop F to discovery check and then he
will pick up your rook so it's very
important to see what is the position of
the King okay so let's go back and see
again how this happened weak pawn you
attack it he pushes the pawn you come
back remember in the end game if
opponent is pushing the pawns every time
you push a pawn in the end game that
means you create a weakness okay so
that's why so we attack we go back now
he comes forward and now we block he
takes we take the pawn and good position
okay good job now let's move forward to
the next example here so let's take a
look at this position and evaluate it
first first I want you to evaluate look
at the position and just tell me who you
think is better and how much slightly
better big advantage perhaps winning
so white to play and you need to convert
this endgame okay
converting to win
we try to see what are the pluses what
are the minuses in this position for
both sides
well that's that could change here
because if you move your king that could
change something else look at look at
something else there is something else
in this position that immediately if you
look what do we see here immediately
when we look at the puns what do we see
aha
double pawns double pants is one thing
but there is something else that I would
like you to mention here that Black has
that Y doesn't have double pants but
what else yes yes that's that's a that's
a platformer
because the bishop is stronger when
there are pawns on both sides of the
board very important detail bishop is
usually stronger than the night when
there are pawns on both sides of the
board but there is something else here
it's nothing to do with the pieces
here's just some another detail that if
you look besides the weak pawns what
else black black hands here
he has less mobility but still I'm still
looking for that one more detail here in
the end game you always count this yeah
he doesn't have so many moves but for us
what about the pawn islands do you count
the islands when you playing when you
reach an endgame do you count how many
islands opponent hence and how many you
have this is very important
how many pawn islands Black has here
three pawn island if you're not familiar
with it it's the pawn that is by itself
so that pawn is one this two is another
island another island not only he has
many pawn islands he also has double
pawns
so basically this is a very very bad
pawn structure but it doesn't mean that
you're just going to win because he has
a bad pawn structure you still have to
play precisely because he has a bishop
and we know that Bishop is stronger when
there are pawns on both sides of the
board so what would be the right plan so
by the way who can tell me the proper
evaluation here what it will be slightly
better for white we know that white is
better is it slightly better is it a big
advantage or it's winning position when
we evaluate a position there are three
things we can say slightly better big
advantage winning position or sometimes
also equal position but I think it's
pretty clear that this is this cannot be
an equal position because black has too
many weaknesses so how much you think
white is better here
big advantage after that aha big
advantage voce big advantage is good
what else anybody thinks white is
winning white is winning
technically white is winning here okay
but probably it's right now if we
evaluate it's a big advantage we can't
just say white is winning yet we have to
still prove that so you would need to
prove that okay and now let's see how we
can prove that white is going to win
this game so what would be the first
move you get one point for finding the
right move here King efore but if you
put the King here what are you planning
to enter the can you enter here now here
now here now see you're going to have
entry points
okay for let me letting go here you
check I go here now I control that d5
square so
somebody also mentioned 94 move you put
it up at 19 so true it's a well placed
here
if you check you're just gonna come up
so we're not making much progress here
King to see 4 correct my one point for
that activating the king you always want
to activate your piece to the maximum
now I activate the King and he's really
now stuck with the c5 weakness he can't
just move the King away you just take
the pawn if he takes your knight King
and pawn endgame when there are no
pieces left on the Kings we call that a
King and pawn endgame cause only Kings
and pawn that so that's King and pawn
endgame it's going to be basically lost
because now he's gonna run out of moves
he comes up push and what do we call
this position sucks wrong okay he has to
go back
you take one what do we call again sucks
around right then we take another one so
this is just winning so he cannot take
the knight so he will play Bishop here
okay we activated a king but how do we
win this position very important idea
you have to find very precise play
needed here yes
good idea but do we want to undo all the
double pawns okay you're saying this
move correct I take you okay I go here
because you go here now I can put the
bishop here
okay so let's go back so we don't want
to play that yet okay that's so what do
you do next year night a for correct
attacking the weak pawn you give your
pawn it's okay but when he takes it not
only you take this pawn now next one
you're also going to take this and he
cannot do anything so he's going to lose
two pounds but still you have to convert
this advantage so let's take a look how
white converts this advantage you wrap a
pawn but still well this might be an
inaccuracy because now suddenly his King
King is going to get active you don't
want to do that so this could be a
problem so that we don't want to do that
so take this should be six we take this
pawn now ninety six egos we should be
three Knight goes back to before Bishop
f4 Knight see two anyway so now it comes
back to default if we can somehow force
this pawn to move it would be good
because we can check now it will weaken
his light squares so now just next move
is push and that comes back to f3
controlling the e5 square so King cannot
enter suddenly and also putting pressure
here we have six and now simply go back
now he wants to start pushing the C pawn
he played c3 King b5q v5c fourth check
kingi for King the six now it's a very
nice position we wrap upon
but still it's you don't really have a
clear-cut win here it's not like he is
going to resign you still have to find
that final touch here so what do you do
here we know it's a winning position but
you still have to win the winning
position at final touch now I need it
yeah it's very nice but when your night
which is d5 maybe just going to Bishop
d8 yeah this takes time this takes time
here you finish this game in just three
moves here very effective finish now
you want to go this way candy you could
but you will probably put this kick back
to be six so block it so your king is
active a knight is also well placed but
where is our advantage in this position
uh-huh uh-huh
passed pawn right passed pawns they're
meant to be pushed so here you pushed
upon so we need to deflect this King
because if we can deflect him and
penetrate with the King we will simply
collect all the weak pawns
imagine your King reaches f7 simply
collect everything and then you just
push the pawns g5h or easy so he has to
now he has no moves he has to go here
now Knight e5 check activating the
knight can he take the pawn can he take
this pawn yeah
share fork winning the bishop not a good
idea and if he takes and let's look at
the King and pawn endgame what's the
best move here what's the best move
King v5 or d6 you want to win this pawn
that's the priority win this pawn first
and now we go here and we can simply now
given the C pawn if you keep the
opposition what do we do push if it goes
away we push the C pawn against us to go
here and push the pawn all the way okay
so this is how you win an endgame like
this where you have a you know you have
a nice advantage but you still need to
find a plan here and the advantages
again because of the double pounds we
have double pawns here for black as
double pawns and also a weak pawn on a6
as well
improve the King to the maximum then you
go Knight a four and ninety-five white
to play and win
no pounds on the board very rare in any
game that there are no ponds on the port
white is extra bishop normally if it's a
normal position this is theoretically
it's a draw but I've won twice against
strong grandmasters so it's not easy to
do in practice so it's a theoretically
this is a draw if it's normal position
this is not like this if normal I mean
if his King is in the middle of the
board he's rookies on a five on line
score normally it's a draw but it's you
could do win I want twice so it's and
also many many games have been won by
you know two grandmasters playing so but
this is different position so you need
to calculate and find a way to take
advantage of the fact that he's rupees
on f6 on reduction any skin is on h8 how
can take advantage of this factor that
you know his pieces on the same diagonal
and you have the bishop of that color
you won't think it's simple it's not
that simple actually you probably see
the first move but very precise
follow-up needed
okay bishop to beat you now if I go
check what do you do you block and you
say check now to block and that gives
you a chance to win the peace same thing
if it goes check we go back say check
okay so if it goes here now what do we
do check and now we win the rock not
check from here this would be an
inaccuracy rook f8 it will block it if
it goes here what do you do check and
you win the rook okay okay so now let's
take a look at some defenses what if it
goes here
you have to double checks which one is
the best check when there are two checks
King must move if King cannot move
anywhere it's checkmate
so remember when two checks immediately
then he has to move the King and now see
rookies guarding the square he can
escape from we go down here
checkmate okay and if he goes this way
now what do you do
check it comes up now rook is guarding
the square checkmate
same idea but a little bit different it
depends where he puts the rock if it
puts on G you go to the c8 if you put on
FL you go to h3 okay good so it looks
like simple yeah we just go here and we
win
now that's simple rook h6 now best
defense still losing but at least it's
more difficult now
let's don't rush don't rush we have to
look to see six King h7 he's protecting
his rook rook to g3 suggestion okay I
come up I'll go back I come up go back I
go back draw would be great for black
black would be extremely happy to save
this game imagine if you don't find the
right move here you're not winning this
game
hey well I mean you have the right idea
route g3 but you have to find it win all
the way here now Roxy some I skip I will
King h8 King h7 now
about this Bishop Siwon all right well
you have the bishop on the right
diagonal
you don't wanna the ship see one is just
an attack you will see it it's a rock
move it's a rock move it's a rock move
- here here he just comes up and
protects his rook if you take this with
a drop because you cannot checkmate with
the bishop you need the pawn at least
okay so ah so now it's not so easy
suddenly huh
not so easy now
one thing you have to cut the king so he
doesn't escape because if he gets to GE
t is going to escape
okay so rubgy three idea was correct
because you cut the king now he can't go
that way
so he was here now this is good too
now you have to be careful because there
are lots of steel made ideas because he
could sacrifice his rook and then you
get a stalemate
what do you do here the key move here
you need to find the key move that is
winning
he escapes King g8
you need the coin he comes up there you
need a quiet Mouse a lot of time in
these positions you need a quiet move to
pass the turn to the opponent keep
everything the way it is but you pass
the turn but accurate the only one move
wins then he goes King g8 he escapes
from the corner he's checked now he
skips to f8 he runs away he runs away
then it's you will play 450 moves and
probably might be a draw King to be won
correct you simply pass the turn now
let's see what this black gonna do you
cannot move the King so if it goes Czech
we drop the route back and you tell him
check and you pick up upon pick up the
rock okay so you cannot do that now the
problem for him is anywhere he moves the
rock you're going to move it that
direction and say check and you're going
to win by doing a discovery check if it
goes rook f6 what do you do don't hurry
up and just take complete say in like if
you have 30 seconds opponent puts a
route that you take quickly still mate
what
yeah hope to g6 or look to any square
pretty much back you take okay
and now if he goes here what do you do
check can go here
it's guarding he goes here check all
right perfect
now let's take a look if it goes rook f8
what do you do now
rook to c7 check
to seven check
perfect same exact idea but now if he
checks from here we're going to go back
here say check and we pick up your rock
see without King a - you cannot win this
position let's say you make this move
right so I want to suggested this I go
check check still mate you come up here
no problem check no matter how you take
still mate check still mate and you go
ahead and just take okay so always have
to watch out for that okay so a lots of
nuances looks like a simple you put the
bishop there and you're going to win but
no you have to see lots of nuances here
one like for example against each mode
the best defense is rook h6 of course
Arouca fate check check and here
remember a lot of times in these
combinations you make check check check
reach a crucial one and then you play a
quiet move okay
King p1
raise your hand if you know this
position very famous position okay good
it's called Lucena
anybody for me with the name Lucena
rookin game one of the most famous
positions in rockin game there's lucina
that is Philidor the two most most
famous positions I will show you
Lucina and after that I will show you
the Philidor okay Philidor is for the
defence Lucina is to win okay
Lucina and it's the name not sure why
probably the person who found this idea
but also no one decided is build the
bridge you basically need to build a
bridge in order to win this this is one
of the most important to rock endgame
positions endgame position general you
have to know so so okay how can we win
this position probably the only way we
can win is if we promote this point to
acclaim
otherwise you cannot win this but it's
not easy in fact if you if his King is
now in front of the pawn it's going to
be a draw okay so what do you do here in
order to be able to promote this pawn
into a queen it takes several steps
slowly inch by inch you improve the
position and after that you build the
bridge
the final step is the building the
bridge before you do that you have to
put the King on f8 part on f7 here you
should be able to reach a position
that's not so difficult and you have to
make sure you keep the king cut he
cannot cross and get in front of the
pawn so you keep that rope there keep
the king cut so what do we do here how
do we get that position
you could go rocky for but is it really
necessary
kingi 5 correct now if he doesn't do
anything we push so he goes check f6 he
goes back attack you push ok he's gonna
keep eye on the pawn go to the side
again push check push ok now we reach
this position very important step here
is his king is too close to your pawn
that means he can catch your pawn in one
move if your king is away he can catch
it by playing one move so what you do is
you push the King away from the pond and
the way you do that when the Kings are
in front of each others what we call
that the position like this opposition
right that means why king is guarding
these 3 squares give a little chick that
instantly moves them away from your pawn
now he needs two moves to catch up on
okay he needs two moves now what should
be our next step
not yet do we don't have the position
yet to put that one more step needs to
be done first continue correct check
good
pawn 12:7 okay now he has to play rook
g'wan if he doesn't play rook g1 he's
not defending well for example if you
just goes here you don't need any breach
anything you just go here control the G
file here go see you just come up your
queen the pond you can't see you're
trying to defend check he goes away your
queen takes takes and we check my with a
rock okay so he has to play rook G 1
because this way if you don't know the
building the bridge method you're not
going to be able to win this game
how do we build the bridge now
let's see Kinki 7 check
check
ge e G check the problem is if you do
that then his King comes in see we got
the king at the right spot this King
movement is not going to work because
he's going to check you he's going to
give you lots of checks right and then
you're going to go here and he's going
to go here and then suddenly he's going
to win your pawn okay if you don't know
how to build the bridge it will be very
pity I get this position where you're
winning in just two three moves but you
will lose a half point you have to know
there are five six in games you must
know one of them is Lucena yes
better building a bridge we do it on the
fourth-ranked the reason if you go to d5
i simply attack okay so that's why your
on we don't do that you bring the rope
to the fourth rank that's how you build
a bridge now he goes up he's keeping the
king cut and now now we walk with the
king we want a queen check we come up
check no rush
check we come up check legs
Quinn you see why I wanted his King to
be two squares away from the pond
because it was one scone he would have
catch it and win the pond okay do you
think you understand how Lucena works
let's see do a little test I'm going to
mix up the position okay happy then you
can do the yeah okay let's see white to
play and win by using the same method
same method you're going to be able to
win this game quite easily once you know
it is easy so first move
first of all King a5 check King b6 we
want to give ourself the square right so
we can push the pawn it goes back d5
correct now goes here be very accurately
you cannot lose your pawn check with the
rook from where d2 because we want to
move his King away so we give a check
now he's away so now he needs two moves
to catch the pawn this is very important
now now next step c7 check
now he has to play rock a3 this is the
best defense but let's say he's not
doing that he goes here now you win
easily without even building the bridge
no not yet
exactly rook a to rook a to and then
King comes up so he goes here he doesn't
have checks now you can actually when
Queen first if you like check takes and
then after the check he has to step away
and we take the rook okay so now he has
to play rook a tree and now rook to d4
exactly now he goes here
check-check
okay let's see if you can find a way now
I didn't show you this movie yet tricky
move now because if I check I already
know you're going to go king b5 and
block with group before and you win what
do you do now
exactly you bring it closer same breech
idea bring it closer you come up and to
d5 alright and now you're 13 to go to p5
King here go here okay great so any
questions you have about this position
what a Lucena okay now we're going to do
an exposition that I mentioned oh by the
way this idea works the same way you can
win if you have pawn on b c d e f and g
okay these files you use the same idea
it works okay if you have a problem a
and h it's not going to work because
it's a very draw if you have a pawn on a
or h file okay now let's take a look at
the Philidor position this is a pretty
bad scenario for block because his king
is on the last strong it's very bad when
your king is on the last rank it's cut
that means cannot move forward and white
is about to advance his king and pushed
upon so looks like very close white is
very close to win but if you know the
idea here you're going to be able to
make a draw here the defensive resource
here Philidor named after a player
Philidor himself he found this idea so
what do you do here to make a draw if
you don't play this move now you're
going to lose
exactly the idea is called rupees six
you cut the king you cannot you always
want him to push the pawn first you
don't want this keen to get in front of
the pawn okay you want the pawn to get a
head first because when the pawn push
he's not going to have a place to hide
his king so when you go down you're
going to start checking you'll see now
let's say he doesn't do anything he goes
here what do you do we're we're
absolutely you have to keep him cut you
gotta make sure you keep them cut six or
8686 I like further away from the king
better so anyway it's going to go here
you're going to go here after trying
couple of times he's going to give up
and it's going to say okay I got a push
what do you do now one inaccurate move
and you can lose one inaccurate move
here correct rook c1 now the point is he
has no place to hide now he cannot get
in front of the phone so now you just
start checking from the back okay
usually in a rookin game when opponent
has a passed pawn you want your rook
behind a passed pawn it's very important
to notice you don't want to route in
front of the passed pawn because if
you're in front your passive in the back
you can defend you can start checking as
well so in the rougane game you always
want to have if opponent has a passport
you try to put your hook behind it not
on the side not in front in behind it
now he comes up he wants to checkmate
he's about to checkmate you but check
now you just give him so many checks
check check as soon as he is away from
his pawn that he cannot protect with the
King you attack if it pushes we take if
it comes here we come up ok ok ok ok
this is silly door position not very
difficult but you have to know it you
must know
Lucina Philidor and the other end games
also ok let's see so let me change this
up a little bit so let's see if you can
hold this end game against me I will be
trying all the tricks to win it ok I
will play with white you play as black
ok it's a draw but let's see if you can
do it
you can play Roxy six excuse me
Roxy five so when you have them cut you
can keep the rock there okay I will try
do something this way
very good go to HR you don't make sure
you don't get carried away thinking
about checks that's what I want I want
you because a lot of times in a quick
games at least I see a lot of players
they try to just check check check
that's what I want but you don't do that
you keep the king cut okay that's the
that's what you're trying to do here
no check check you good good bad for you
no choice
I got a push
correct again no need to check no need
to give any unnecessary checks you keep
them cut okay
excuse me
correct
c6 okay
well I'll take the rook oh I take the
rook question is now what do you do now
see after trying for a while is going to
try for the last trick propose propose
the exchange of the rooks you don't find
the right move you could very easily
lose now or make it more difficult the
defensive task here who knows the King
and pawn endgame is the win or a draw
exactly okay let's take a look you take
okay you come up because his King cannot
get in front of the pawn so that means
he cannot win now you want to come up
and win the pawn so he has to go back
what are you going to do get the
opposition this is called opposition
when Kings in front of each other once
good its opposition if it's more than
one square it's a distant opposition
this is what regular opposition so if he
goes back you just go in front of the
pan so he has to push
three moves you have two of them losing
one draw losing see I get you out and I
Quinn
in front of the king you make a move
Kings in front of each other it's his
move that means you have the opposition
he pushes in front of the pawn he has to
go here
still mate okay this is very important
to notice king and pine because many
endgames are drawn because you have this
resource here so if I go here if you
don't exchange then there are some
chances you could lose okay so you have
to make sure you exchange and you know
this position okay I'm going to try the
last try to go for this idea as soon as
he pushes the pawn where the King has no
place to hide what do you do you go down
all the way down because if it checks
you just come up if it checks you just
go back so now he has to go here what do
you do check
check
check-check
constantly checking it constantly
checking check is away from the pond
where he cannot protect it what do you
do
perfect rookie one yeah it was so we go
back because you don't want to just keep
on checking if you could win a pond you
want to win a pond just fix the draw he
comes up now what do you do King is
seven and we take the pond
okay so very important to most popular
routine games we'll study today Philidor
this one and the lucena okay very
important to notice endian positions